This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies? Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all?
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人保证。每个陪伴孩子做午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。他们终于会吃蔬菜了吗？帕斯塔面能在第一口后幸存吗？饭盒带回家时会是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？
And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on Internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit. Visit bell.ca for details and to check availability. Bell, connection is everything. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the survivor files.
你能在切好黄瓜之前看完第8集吗？选择Bell纯光纤网络，搭配Craved Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94加元起。两年期网络合同及自动扣款优惠可享受两年价格保证。访问bell.ca了解详情并查询可用性。Bell，连接就是一切。我曾在被囚禁中度过了九个月，我用一生去探索其他人是如何在那些本该毁灭他们的绝境中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是“幸存者档案”。
Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your
每周，我都会陪伴那些经历过不可思议之事的幸存者，他们曾被绑架、尾随、控制，甚至险些被剥夺声音。这些故事讲述了活着逃脱所需付出的代价。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。Pro Society是一个每周播客，它既像是一个读书俱乐部，又像是一个群聊，专为那些认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度讨论的人而设。每周，我们都会将书籍、网络和流行文化与您最喜爱的作家、读书博主以及大量深思熟虑的观点联系起来。
favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space.
我很着迷。我太着迷了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Pro Society。我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby》的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和有用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒向有抱负的演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提供建议时那样。你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间。
You're hired to fill the space. with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology.
你被雇佣是为了用你来填补这个空间。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby》。在全新播客Solita中，我们分享了女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮涅罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的空间，我可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代怜悯。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Solita。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你的二十多岁心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十多岁时最大的变化、时刻和过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast and thank you for joining me for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. So today I want to talk about this kind of this idea or theory that I've been playing around with and exploring in kind of recent months. I talk a lot about the quarter life crisis on this podcast, which is, you know, the period in our early to mid-20s when we're just struck by all these compounding questions and fears all at once and it feels like everything is going wrong. We have no sense of stability, no sense of direction, purpose. Our lives are falling apart. But equally, we feel like our lives are just starting and we're the oldest we've ever been, where the youngest
大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，感谢大家和我一起收听又一期节目，我们在这里剖析二十多岁的心理。所以今天我想聊聊这种我一直在思考并在过去几个月里探索的想法或理论。我在这个播客里经常谈到四分之一人生危机，也就是我们在二十岁出头到三十岁左右时，突然被所有这些交织在一起的问题和恐惧击中，感觉一切都出了问题的时期。我们没有任何稳定感、方向感或目标感。我们的生活正在崩塌。但同样地，我们觉得生活才刚刚开始，我们既是经历过的最年长的自己，又是经历过的最年轻的
we've ever been. It's like this crazy moment. It's a ride of passage, even though it feels like no one else has ever experienced it before. And it's very terrifying because we kind of hope to exit it as quickly as it starts and we hope that we exit it better than how we entered it. That's our quarter life crisis. We kind of have no guarantee of where it's taking us, but we just kind of have to have hope. The quarter life crisis, you know, is a lot about shedding all things and the destruction of an old life. But there's this other phenomena that accompanies it that I think is spoken about less, mainly because, A, it's very subtle. And B, it's something that can only be recognized in hindsight.
自己。这就像是一个疯狂的时刻。这是一个成长的仪式，尽管感觉好像从来没有人经历过类似的事情。这非常可怕，因为我们希望像它开始时一样快地摆脱它，我们希望摆脱它的状态比进入它时更好。这就是我们的四分之一人生危机。我们有点无法保证它会把我们带向何方，但我们只能怀抱希望。四分之一人生危机，很大程度上关乎抛弃旧事物和旧生活的毁灭。但伴随它而来的还有另一个现象，我认为讨论得较少，主要是因为，第一，它非常微妙；第二，它只有在事后才能被认出来。
And it's the idea of the quarter-life reinvention. This thing I have seen time and time again where people emerge from their quarter-life crisis at 26, 27, 28, maybe even in the 30s, completely different people to who they were at 22, 23, 23, 24. And it's not just normal development. Something intrinsic shifts in them, but also physical and emotional. And at the tail end of the quarter-life crisis, they get this almost second-puburn. or second growth spurt that completely changes the trajectory of their lives psychologically and
这就是四分之一人生重塑的概念。我一次又一次地看到这种现象：人们在26、27、28岁，甚至30多岁时从四分之一人生危机中走出，变成了与22、23、23、24岁时完全不同的人。这不仅仅是正常的发育。某种内在的东西发生了转变，同时也伴随着生理和情感上的变化。在四分之一人生危机的尾声，他们几乎迎来了第二次发育青春期或第二次生长突增，这在心理和情感上彻底改变了他们的人生轨迹。
emotionally. Unlike, again, like I said, the quarter life crisis, which is depicted as the collapse, the quarter life reinvention is the expansion and growth of something. And it is this transformation that seems to only be able to take place when everything unnecessary has fallen away. So, I want to talk about it today. I want to talk about the psychology. behind it, the phases that we move through when we go through a quarter life crisis, and how to know when you are getting close to the reinvention stage, how to get yourself there, not faster, but with less friction and what to expect. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of the quarter life reinvention.
与之前提到的四分之一人生危机被描绘成崩溃不同，四分之一人生重塑是某种事物的扩张和生长。这种转变似乎只有在所有不必要的东西都剥落之后才会发生。所以，今天我想谈谈它。我想谈谈背后的心理学，我们在经历四分之一人生危机时所经历的阶段，以及如何知道自己何时接近重塑阶段、如何让自己到达那里（不是更快，而是以更少的摩擦），以及期待什么。闲话少说，让我们进入四分之一人生重塑的心理学。
So the idea of the quarter life crisis, I know I've kind of explained it already, but I think it's one we're fairly familiar with. It is a distinct period in our lives where we experience a rapid onset of confusion, self-doubt and anxiety that we aren't living our lives as we should be. I think the kind of fantasy and ease of our childhood, of our teen years, of our early adulthood seems to just like slip away overnight and we basically realize almost all at once, like wait a second. Like this is getting very serious.
所以关于四分之一人生危机的概念，我知道我已经解释过了，但我认为这是我们都相当熟悉的。这是我们生命中一个独特的时期，我们会经历突如其来的困惑、自我怀疑和焦虑，觉得我们的生活没有按照应有的方式进行。我认为童年、青少年时期、成年初期的那种幻想和轻松似乎在一夜之间消逝了，我们几乎同时意识到，等一下。这变得非常严重。
And soon after we are like, well, if this is getting serious, do I want to be in the life this is leading me to? It's definitely going to cause you to examine a whole lot. And there is a choice. Keep going this way or pivot, redirect change. The choice to redirect or the moments where we feel forced to redirect are where a lot of the tension and the anxiety come from. It borrows its name, the quarter left crisis, borrows its name from the more one. widely known, well, I don't even think it's more widely known anymore, but the original idea of the midlife crisis. The midlife crisis was a critical life stage, first observed by the psychologist
不久之后，我们就会想，如果这变得很严重，我想过上这种生活引导我去的生活吗？这绝对会促使你进行大量的审视。这里有一个选择：继续这样走下去，或者转换方向、重新定向、改变。选择重新定向或我们感到被迫重新定向的时刻，正是许多紧张感和焦虑感的来源。“四分之一人生危机”这个名字借用了更广为人知的（好吧，我甚至不认为它现在更广为人知了）中年危机的最初概念。中年危机是心理学家埃利奥特·雅克在20世纪60年代首次观察到的一种关键生命阶段
Elliot Jacques in the 1960s, who kind of stood in front of this co-holt of British psychologists and said, all of us, a lot of people are going to go through this period at midlife where they get really depressed and they get really unhappy. And we need to talk about it. And he had seen it time and time again in patience. He'd read about it in biographies. He'd observed it in himself and family and friends. People reached what he called the crest of the hill, the halfway point of life, and realized the, you know, the trajectory so far had been up and up and up and up. And now inevitably, they're at the top of the hill, they're halfway through life and it's all down. It's leading towards death. The years are fewer in front than behind. It's a very existential moment for
他站在一群英国心理学家面前说，我们所有人、许多人都会在人生中期经历这个时期，他们会变得非常沮丧和不快乐。我们需要谈谈这个。他在患者身上一次又一次地看到了这一点，他在传记中读到过，在自己、家人和朋友身上也观察到过。人们达到了他所谓的“山顶”，即人生的中点，并意识到迄今为止的轨迹一直在上升、上升、上升。现在不可避免地，他们站在山顶上，走到了人生的中途，一切都在走下坡路。它通向死亡。前方的岁月比身后的岁月要少。对许多人来说，这是一个非常存在主义的时刻，
many people, and he observed people doing very irrational things, very strange things to maintain their sense of youth. Suddenly, they're leaving marriages with people they seem to love. Suddenly, they're spending all their savings on ridiculous things like red sports cars. They're having these out of the blue, they're quitting their jobs, they're doing crazy stuff, is what he said. And so he originally only identified one point like this in our life. And then people kind of took that idea and they said, wait a second, I think this happens more than once. Eric Erickson, the famous psychologist, said, I think this happens in our 20s, but it didn't really gain traction for a while that it would happen during our 20s. People thought people were too young. But then as our life
他观察到人们做出非常不理智的事情、非常奇怪的事情来维持他们的青春感。突然间，他们离开了那些他们似乎深爱的人的婚姻。突然间，他们把所有的积蓄花在红色跑车之类荒谬的事情上。他们会突然毫无征兆地辞职，做一些疯狂的事，他是这么说的。因此，他最初在我们的生活中只确定了这样一个点。然后人们采纳了这个想法并说，等一下，我认为这发生不止一次。著名的心理学家埃里克·埃里克森说，我认为这发生在我们的二十多岁，但它在二十多岁时发生并没有真正流行起来。人们认为人们还太年轻。但后来随着我们的生活
expectancy increased, you know, the global average has gone from 52 in the 60s to like 74. These days, that's a 40% difference, if I have my math correct. Like when that happened, people were like, okay, yeah, this is more distinct. There is a crisis that happens around our 20s that we can't ignore this. Just simply more life to worry about we're going to have more moments of crisis. What we realize now and what I have to give credit for to the authors Alexander Robbins and Abby Wilner for articulating for the first time in their book, The Quarter Life Crisis, is that life is not this big clump of years stretching out before us one after the other, often just slightly different but mostly the same. There are these inflection points where things change
预期增加，你知道的，全球平均寿命从60年代的52岁上升到现在的74岁左右，如果我的数学没算错的话，这是一个40%的差异。当这种情况发生时，人们觉得，好吧，是的，这更独特了。在我们的二十多岁左右确实会发生一场我们无法忽视的危机。只是有更多的人生需要担心，我们会有更多的危机时刻。我们现在意识到的，以及我要感谢作家亚历山大·罗宾斯和艾比·威尔纳在他们的书《四分之一人生危机》中首次阐明的是，生活并不是一大堆岁月像这样前后相连地延伸在我们面前，通常只是略有不同但大同小异。存在着一些拐点，事情一下子迅速发生变化，我们的身份、未来、希望和梦想似乎因为我们掌控之中和之外的事情而被颠覆。
rapidly all at once and our identity, our future, our hopes and dreams seem to just be flipped because of things within and outside of our control. Like a breakup, grief, losing your job, like you move to a new place and then six months past and you're like, who am I? Like, who am I? I don't even recognize who I was six months ago. All these things can trigger this cascade of other changes. And with it, a complete instability and a reassessment of like, what do I want from my life? Who am I? What am I doing here? That's the quarter life crisis. And it's a funny thing because it's not just contained to a couple of years at 22 or 23. It can be experienced as young as 18. It can last for seven plus years or more. And something I rarely see spoken about,
比如分手、悲伤、失业，比如你搬到一个新地方，然后六个月过去了，你问自己：“我是谁？我是谁？我甚至不认识六个月前的自己了。”所有这些事情都会引发一连串的其他变化，并随之带来彻底的不稳定性以及对以下问题的重新评估：我对生活有什么期望？我是谁？我在这里做什么？这就是四分之一人生危机。这是一件很有趣的事情，因为它不仅仅局限于22或23岁的几年里。它甚至可以在18岁时经历。它可以持续七年甚至更久。而且我很少听到别人谈论的一点是，
is that you can have more than one quarter-life crisis. In fact, you will likely have a couple, two, in fact. And they're very, very different. This 2019 paper published in the journal Emerging Addothood found that these two distinct types of quarter-life crisis are called the locked-out and the locked-in quarter-life crisis. The locked-in-kind is when you feel trapped in your circumstances and you just don't know how to change.
你可能会经历不止一次四分之一人生危机。事实上，你很可能会经历几次，具体来说是两次。而且它们非常非常不同。这篇发表在2019年《新兴成年期》杂志上的论文发现，这两种截然不同的四分之一人生危机被称为“被锁在外面的”和“被锁在里面的”四分之一人生危机。“被锁在里面”的那种是指你觉得自己被困在目前的处境中，却不知道该如何改变。
the locked out kind is when you know you need to change, but you don't know how to access the next part of your life that you want. You have a better idea of your desired life. You just don't know how to get there. And both of these moments are equally crisis creating. When I reflect on, you know, my own life, when I reflect on my own life, but yeah, when I do, I can see these two types of crises so distinctly, especially in hindsight. You know, I went through such a confusing period, maybe like three or four years ago where it was just like, none of this is working, nothing is changing, I feel stuck here, I don't want to be here, I don't know what I want. I was working a corporate job. I was dating these, like, quite frankly, like these losers. I didn't really exercise. I
“被锁在外面的”那种是指你知道自己需要改变，但你不知道如何接触到你想要的下一阶段的生活。你对你想要的生活有了更好的了解。你只是不知道如何到达那里。这两种时刻同样都会制造危机。当我反思我自己的生活时，当我反思我自己的生活时，是的，当我这样做时，我能如此清晰地看到这两种类型的危机，尤其是在事后。你知道，我经历了这样一个令人困惑的时期，大概是三四年前，当时的感觉是：这一切都不起作用，没有任何改变，我感觉自己被困在这里，我不想呆在这里，我不知道我想要什么。我当时在一家公司上班。我和这些坦白说就像是失败者的家伙约会。我真的不锻炼，我
didn't really have any friends because all I did was work and all I did was sit at home. And that was my locked-in crisis. And then I kind of forced my way out. I kind of like violently crossed that threshold by just seriously having a pep talk with myself and being like, hey, you don't want this. Get out of here. And what followed was this waiting room period where I felt good about myself that I'd gotten out of those situations, felt happier because I'd escaped. What I saw was my main containers. And then in like 2024, 2025, I experienced the second kind of quarter life crisis, which was the locked out kind, where it was like, all about striving and trying to picture or obtain something better. And just not knowing how, not knowing if it would
真的没有朋友，因为我所做的就是工作，我所做的就是坐在家里。那就是我被锁在里面的危机。然后我有点强迫自己走出来。我通过非常认真地对自己进行一番谈话，对自己说“嘿，你并不想要这个。离开这里”，从而有些激烈地跨过了那个门槛。随之而来的是一个候诊室时期，因为我走出了那些困境而对自己的现状感到满意，因为我逃脱了而感到更快乐。我看到的是我的主要容器。然后在大约2024年、2025年，我经历了第二种四分之一人生危机，也就是被锁在外面的那一种，当时的一切都是关于奋斗，试图想象或获得更好的东西。而只是不知道如何做到，不知道它是否会
work, it was kind of like, wait, didn't I already do the hard part? Like, I got out of that bad situation. Surely this next bit is easy. And through those years, I was so fixated on, like, how do I do something about this? What do I do? What do I change? What I didn't realize was that something was kind of shifting in the background. Small events, small things were accumulating. And they've brought me to where I am now and what I've experienced specifically in the past six months, which is what we're talking about today, which is the quarter life reinvention. And it happened very slowly. The big distinction between the quarter life crisis and the quarter life reinvention is that your quarter life crisis is all about shedding. It's all about
起作用，那种感觉就像是，等等，我难道不是已经经历了艰难的部分吗？我走出了那种糟糕的状况。毫无疑问，接下来的部分很容易。在那些年里，我太过于执着于：我该怎么做？我该做什么？我该改变什么？我没有意识到的是，有些事情正在背景中发生转变。小事件、小事情在积累。它们把我带到了现在的位置，以及我特别在过去六个月里所经历的事情，也就是我们今天要谈论的，即四分之一人生重塑。这发生得非常缓慢。四分之一人生危机和四分之一人生重塑之间的巨大区别在于，你的四分之一人生危机完全关乎抛弃。它完全关乎
removing yourself from situations and it's all about goodbyes, it's about grief. The Quarter Life Reinvention is all about expansion and addition and things coming in to fill the space the crisis left. Both of them will stretch you. They just stretch you in different ways. It's as if for me, everything reached its final point. Everything has been building up for this final chapter of my quarter of my quarter life crisis where the cycle is complete. There's been one last struggle and I've emerged as like the person this period was meant to make me into, if that makes sense. At some point something just switches, it switches over and the actions and the decisions you made sometimes years ago come back around and finally pay off and you suddenly look in the
把自己从情境中抽离出来，它完全关乎告别，关乎悲伤。而四分之一人生重塑则完全关乎扩张、增加，以及让事物进来填补危机留下的空间。这两者都会让你感到紧绷。它们只是以不同的方式让你感到紧绷。对我来说，就好像一切都达到了最后的高潮。一切都在为我四分之一人生危机的最后一章做铺垫，此时这个周期已经完整了。经历了最后一次挣扎，我作为这个时期注定要将我塑造而成的人浮出水面，如果这说得通的话。在某个时刻，某些东西发生了转变，它翻转过来了，有时甚至是几年前你做出的行动和决定又回过头来，最终得到了回报，你突然照了照
mirror and you're like, wait, I really feel like myself again. I strangely look like myself again. You notice every small change you have made, and there is this sense of calm of like, I push through this. For example, and this may be a bit of a tangent, but for the first time in a decade, I'm like, I have my natural hair color again.
镜子，然后说：“等等，我真的觉得自己又找回了自己。”我奇怪地看起来又像我自己了。你注意到了你所做每一个微小的改变，并且有一种平静感：“我挺过来了。”例如，这可能有点离题，但十年来我第一次觉得：我又拥有了自然的天然发色。
I'm suddenly wearing less makeup. I have this, like, deep ease in my relationships, my hobbies that I had when I was a child have come back. Like I've been up late reading at night. My spark has come back. It's like this, I've returned to the self as a different version of the self. This is your quarter life reinvention. And if we think about the quarter life crisis is four stages, I do think that it is the final stage and the research supports that. We're going to take a short break here. When we return, I want to explicitly talk through those four stages, how to tell when you're at the end of the fourth stage, the one that I'm currently in. And I guess what we need to do to get there. So stay with us. Behind every night spent making the kids' lunches, there's a lot of suspense. Will they finally eat the veggies?
我突然化更少的妆了。我在人际关系中感到了这种深深的轻松，我小时候的那些爱好又回来了。就像我一直在深夜读书一样。我的灵感又回来了。就像是，我以一个不同版本的自己回归了自我。这就是你的四分之一人生重塑。如果我们把四分之一人生危机看作是四个阶段，我的确认为这是最后阶段，研究也支持这一点。我们在这里休息一下。回来后，我想明确探讨这四个阶段，如何判断你是否处于第四阶段的尾声（也就是我目前所处的阶段），以及我想探讨我们需要做些什么才能到达那里。所以请继续关注我们。陪伴孩子做午餐的夜晚背后，都充满了悬念。他们终于会吃蔬菜了吗？
Will the pastos survive the first bite? Will the lunchbox come home empty, half full, or come home at all? And will you finish episode 8 before you're done slicing the cucumbers? Get Bell Pure Fiber Internet with Craved Netflix and Disney Plus from $94 a month. Price guaranteed for two years on internet with a two-year term and auto pay credit.
帕斯塔面能在第一口后幸存吗？饭盒带回家时会是空的、半满的，还是根本没带回来？你能在切好黄瓜之前看完第8集吗？选择Bell纯光纤网络，搭配Craved Netflix和Disney Plus，每月只需94加元起。两年期网络合同及自动扣款优惠可享受两年价格保证。
Visit bell.com for details and to check availability. Bell. Connection is everything. When I was 14 years old, I was kidnapped and held captive for nine months. I survived, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the Survivor Files. I just remember this low, taunting voice next to my ear saying, shut up, don't say anything. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinker. I knew if he woke up, without a doubt, he was going to hurt me.
访问bell.com了解详情并查询可用性。Bell，连接就是一切。当我14岁的时候，我被绑架并被囚禁了九个月。我幸存了下来，我用一生去探索其他人是如何在那些本该毁灭他们的绝境中幸存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这是“幸存者档案”。我只记得耳边传来一个低沉、嘲弄的声音说：闭嘴，什么也别说。每周，我都会陪伴那些经历过不可思议之事的幸存者。我当时就知道，如果他醒来，毫无疑问他会伤害我。
I started feeling that there was someone at the end of my bed, and I just started screaming. They are abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced. But these aren't stories about what's taken from them. There's stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to the Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your for-you page are equally important to your personality, welcome home.
我开始觉得我的床头有人，然后我开始尖叫。他们被绑架、尾随、控制，甚至险些被剥夺声音。但这些并不是关于被夺走的故事。这些故事讲述了活着逃脱所需付出的代价。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎回家。
This is Prose Society, the weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for thought daughters, pop culture obsessives, and anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. I'm Eli Rallo, and every week we're connecting the dots
这里是Prose Society，这是一档每周播出的播客，它既是读书俱乐部，又是思想新女性、流行文化狂热爱好者以及所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等深度探讨的人的群聊。我是伊莉·拉洛（Eli Rallo），每周我们都在将各种线索联系起来
between books, the internet, and the conversations everyone can't stop having. I'm going to have to look up this story. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. From bestselling authors and your favorite book talk creators to the latest pop culture moments, nothing is off the table.
连接书籍、互联网以及每个人都在热议的话题。我得去查查这个故事。我太痴迷了。我太痴迷了。从畅销书作家、你最喜欢的图书创作者，到最新的流行文化时刻，一切皆有可能。
It's like if you can hide some real messages inside compelling characters, then that is a Trojan horse. Whether you're looking for literary deep dives, smart pop culture conversations, or a community of readers who love to think a little too much, you're in the right place.
这就好比如果你能把一些真实的讯息藏在引人入胜的角色之中，那这就是一只特洛伊木马。无论你在寻找深度的文学探讨、聪明的流行文化对话，还是一个喜欢过度思考的读者社区，你都来对地方了。
Listen to pro society on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. See you between the pages. Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook on the Big Money Players Network. Our show is extremely accessible to first-time listeners. Each week, we talk to someone in show business, aka the biz,
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Prose Society。我们在字里行间相见。嘿，我是海斯·达文波特（Hayes Davenport）。还有肖恩·克莱门茨（Sean Clements）。我们是“大钱玩家”网络（Big Money Players Network）播客节目《好莱坞手册》（Hollywood Handbook）的主持人。我们的节目对第一次收听的听众非常友好。每周，我们都会采访一位演艺圈人士，也就是所谓的“圈内人”，
and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman. Not that great. Actually, can you help me shape this? How about we flip it on his head, right? How about we flip this script? Okay.
并试着帮助他们的事业，看看他们能给我们提供什么。每个人都度过了一段美好的时光，没有人会因为他们的公关让他们上我们的节目而生气的。我们有很多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼（Sarah Sherman）。其实也没有那么好。话说回来，你能帮我梳理一下这个思路吗？我们把它反过来讲怎么样？把这个剧本翻转一下？好的。
What is the surprise woman who actually you think is the straight man is actually the one who's acting weird? Adam Scott, this entire time you've been expecting Adam Sandler to come to visit the show. I would never expect. I have. I would never set expectations for something like that to happen. If the universe allows for something like that to happen, I don't. I am open to it. I'm always going to accept.
这个惊喜在于，你以为是个正常人的那个女人，其实才是表现奇怪的人？亚当·斯科特（Adam Scott），这段时间你一直期待亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）来做客节目。我绝不会这样期望。我有过。我绝不会对这种事情的发生设定预期。如果宇宙允许这样的事情发生，我不会。我是持开放态度的。我总是会接受的。
You know, Danny McBride, fine. Yeah, it's all this fragile masculinity. Exuding. I could smell it walking on the hallway, to be honest with you. I was like, is that weed? Nope, it's fragile masculinity. Ben Stiller, no. Because a lot of times, out of context, people don't get it
你知道的，丹尼·麦克布莱德（Danny McBride），也行。是的，全是这种脆弱的男性气质。散发着。说实话，我走在走廊里就能闻到。我当时想，那是大麻吗？不，那是脆弱的男性气质。本·斯蒂勒（Ben Stiller），不行。因为很多时候，脱离了语境，人们根本不理解
or even know what a circle is. You know what I mean? They're like, they're so stupid. Everyone's so dumb. And fake. Right. fake and also not interested or just like, oh, I've got
甚至不知道什么是小圈子。你知道我的意思吗？他们就觉得，他们太蠢了。每个人都太蠢了。而且很虚伪。没错。虚伪而且还心不在焉，或者只是觉得，哦，我有
my life, I don't care about your life. And a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are without us. Oh, and by the way, Will Ferrell told us personally he loves the show and he wants to be a guest on every episode, but he's just so busy. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast Solita, we share the messy reality of
我自己的生活，我才不在乎你的生活。还有许多其他的大人物，如果没有我们，他们就不会有今天的成就。哦，顺便说一句，威尔·法瑞尔（Will Ferrell）亲自告诉我们他很喜欢这个节目，他想成为每一集的嘉宾，但他实在是太忙了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在新播客Solita中，我们分享了
traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word solita, trading the pity for possibility. Every time I tried to be alone, I kept meeting people, and they were like, you smiled at us.
女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了B选项。我是朱莉·皮内罗（Julie Pinero），我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的可以不用先问任何人就能说“好”的空间。我的使命是重新定义“Solita”这个词，用可能性取代同情。每次我试图独处时，我总是能遇到人，他们会说，你对我们笑了。
Not a lot of people smile around here. It's when you're alone that you're most receptive to the world as it is, not the lies you're sold about it. It can be a time where you push your limits, change your mind, or wake up to a new version of yourself. So whether you're a solo travel veteran or you're too nervous to book your first trip, I hope you listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So there is a theory put forth by three researchers in the UK that our quarter life crisis, or what they call the early adult crisis, their article, happens in four stages. So these researchers, they conducted 50 structured and
这里很少有人笑。正是在你独处的时候，你才最能接受世界的本来面目，而不是关于它向你兜售的谎言。这段时间可以让你突破极限、改变想法，或者唤醒一个全新版本的自己。所以，无论你是一个独自旅行的老手，还是紧张得不敢预订你的第一次旅行，我都希望你在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听Solita。英国的三位研究人员提出了这样一个理论：我们的四分之一人生危机，或者他们所说的早期成年危机，他们在文章中指出，分为四个阶段。所以这些研究人员进行了50次结构化的
in-depth interviews with different types of people in their 20s to try and see if the quarter-life crisis followed any specific kind of route or like had any landmarks to it. And what they found was that yes, yes, it did. There was a route, there was a progression that a lot of us will follow. The first stage was that locked in or locked out trigger. Something makes us realize like, I'm not happy, and I would like to be happier. The reason we feel trapped in this moment is often extrinsic is what they found. So it's social pressure, family pressure, financial pressure, relationship pressure. Something makes us feel like we should stay or we can't leave, but we reach a point of crisis inevitably. We're maintaining our false outward identity becomes too much. The distress is
对20多岁不同类型人群的深度采访，试图了解四分之一人生危机是否遵循任何特定的路线，或者是否有任何标志性的事件。他们发现，是的，确实如此。有一条路线，有一个我们许多人都会遵循的发展进程。第一阶段是“锁定”或“排斥”的触发点。有些事情让我们意识到：我不快乐，我想变得快乐。研究发现，我们此时感到被困住的原因往往是外在的。也就是社会压力、家庭压力、财务压力、人际关系压力。有些事情让我们觉得我们应该留下来，或者我们无法离开，但我们不可避免地达到了危机点。我们维持虚假的外在身份变得不堪重负。痛苦是
too great. The unhappiness is too bitter and we break. We're forced or something forces us to change pretty rapidly. This moves us into the separation and time out phase. We detach from the old commitment or way of life. And this brings about the most emotionally intense stage of just like panic and shame and anxiety and pressure. This is the crisis period. It's also where we experience a transitional state we know in psychology as the identity vacuum. The identity vacuum can happen at heaps of different times in our lives. For example, it often occurs quite profoundly for new immigrants, new parents, people going through divorce when we retire. It also happens during our quarter life crisis.
太剧烈了。不快乐太痛苦了，我们崩溃了。我们被迫或某种力量迫使我们相当迅速地改变。这让我们进入了分离和冷静期。我们脱离了旧的承诺或生活方式。这带来了情感上最激烈的阶段，充满了恐慌、羞耻、焦虑和压力。这就是危机期。这也是我们经历心理学上所说的“身份真空”的过渡状态。身份真空可能在我们生活中的许多不同时间发生。例如，它经常深刻地发生在有新移民、新父母、经历离婚的人以及我们退休的时候。它也会发生在我们的四分之一人生危机期间。
And it's as the name describes, everything has been sucked up. And we're left feeling empty, untethered, and grieving our old self. How long we stay here depends on a few things. But these researchers believed it really depends on critically how much time out you give yourself to reflect, grieve, maybe travel, rediscover, try new things. How much time you're going to. give yourself to do that, all of which pushes you into the exploration phase. This is where we are actively trying and also somewhat failing at putting our identity back together. Our identity still
正如其名，一切都被吸空了。我们感到空虚、漂泊，并为旧的自我感到悲伤。我们在那里呆多久取决于几个因素。但这些研究人员认为，这关键取决于你给自己多少时间去反思、悲伤、也许去旅行、重新发现、尝试新事物。你要给自己多少时间去做这些，所有这些都将你推向探索阶段。在这里，我们正在积极地尝试，但在把我们的身份重新拼凑起来时也有点失败。我们的身份仍然
remains quite shaky. It's still in the vacuum stage, but we are trying on new things and throwing them into the vacuum. We're trying on different identities, see if they fit. I tried being a runner. Didn't fit, but I needed to try it. I tried reinventing my wardrobe, my style. I thought I might be somebody who likes parting again, which I wasn't. I was just trying on different things. The trying is the important part. Nothing works for a while. You feel hopeless, but it is behind the scenes what is propelling you into reinvention
显得相当不稳固。它仍处于真空阶段，但我们在尝试新事物并把它们扔进真空中。我们在尝试不同的身份，看它们是否合身。我试过跑步。不合身，但我需要尝试一下。我试着重塑我的衣橱，我的风格。我以为我可能是一个喜欢重新去派对的人，其实我不是。我只是在尝试不同的东西。尝试才是最重要的部分。有一段时间什么都不管用。你感到绝望，但在幕后，正是这些在推动你走向重塑
and the rebuilding phase where, as we spoke about, the accumulation of our courage and our risk and our hard decisions pays off. This is the final stage, the quarter life reinvention. and here is how you know you are in it and what it demands of you. Firstly, you know you are in the final quarter life reinvention stage when a few things about your life start to feel more settled, but not in the I have settled way. What I mean by that is that you've found ordinary aspects of life you actually like and that fit you better.
和重建阶段，正如我们所讨论的，我们的勇气、风险和艰难决定的积累得到了回报。这是最后一个阶段，四分之一人生重塑。以下是你如何知道自己身处其中以及它对你的要求。首先，当你生活中的一些事情开始感觉更加安定时，你就知道自己进入了最后的四分之一人生重塑阶段，但这并不是那种“我已经将就了”的方式。我的意思是，你找到了你真正喜欢并更适合你的生活的平凡方面。
It's not that you've settled by any means, it's that you have chosen deliberately and you are happy with those choices compared to your previous choices. You feel good about them. Secondly, you start genuinely making decisions because you want to make those decisions, not because others want you to. It's like there is this additional layer added into your decision-making process that you haven't had before where your own urges and your own instincts matter more, which means, thirdly, you stop performing. There is no longer this character or persona you're trying to play. You experience something we call in psychology identity congruence.
这绝不是说你妥协了，而是你深思熟虑地做出了选择，与你先前的选择相比，你对这些选择感到满意。你对它们感觉良好。其次，你开始真正地做决定，因为你想做这些决定，而不是因为别人想让你这样做。这就好像在你的决策过程中加入了一个你以前没有的新层面，你自己的冲动和直觉变得更重要了，这意味着，第三，你不再表演了。你不再试图扮演某个角色或人格。你体验到了我们在心理学上称之为身份一致性的东西。
Basically, there is an alignment between your core self-image, your core beliefs, desires, and also how you act. Carl Jung literally called it the dropping of the persona. You essentially feel like a more enlightened and perhaps confident version of yourself, of one you probably haven't felt in a very long time. Next, you find you can manage your anxiety around, is this all going to work out? Even if that comes slowly, you feel more secure.
基本上，你的核心自我形象、核心信念、愿望以及你的行为之间存在着一种契合。卡尔·荣格（Carl Jung）直截了当地称之为卸下假面具。你基本上会觉得自己是一个更开明、或许也更自信的自己，这种感觉你可能已经很久没有过了。接下来，你会发现你可以控制自己对“这一切最终会成功吗？”的焦虑。即使这种感觉来得很慢，你也会感到更有安全感。
This has been the biggest sign for me that I am on the tail end of my own crisis. My mental space used to be dominated by thoughts of like, how do I know this is the right decision? How do I know I won't have regrets? What if this all goes wrong? What if the outcome isn't what I exactly expected? And now I can look at those thoughts and be like, okay, I'll make it work. I know I can trust myself. I know my character is strong. It's like the lessons of the crisis are all landing at once. They're finally making some sense.
对我来说，这是我正处于自己危机尾声的最大迹象。我的精神空间过去常常被这样的想法所主导：我怎么知道这是正确的决定？我怎么知道我不会后悔？如果这一切都搞砸了呢？如果结果不是我完全预期的那样呢？现在我可以看着这些想法，然后想：好吧，我会让它成功的。我知道我可以信任我自己。我知道我的性格很坚强。就好像危机的教训一下子全盘呈现了。它们终于变得有些意义了。
And so the dread, when I didn't have those lessons, is fading. Your intuition also gets louder. You have a deeper sense of knowing about what you want, as I said, knowing a little bit of how to get there, knowing that you need a bit of audacity. And finally, I think you just feel more present. You feel more in your own life. I think this signifies the shift out of survival and panic mode into curiosity and building mode. We know from extensive psychological research that when we are facing life-changing circumstances and our body and mind is under and immense stress. Our capacity for creativity and for curiosity and for expansion and trial and error and fulfillment is much lower because it's not a survival priority. As we exit this stage though,
因此，当我没有吸取那些教训时的恐惧正在消退。你的直觉也变得更强了。正如我所说，你对你想要什么有了更深层次的了解，对如何实现目标有了些许了解，知道你需要一点勇气。最后，我想你会觉得更当下。你会觉得更多地活在自己的生活中。我认为这标志着从生存和恐慌模式向好奇心和建设模式的转变。我们从大量的心理学研究中得知，当我们面临改变生活的环境，并且我们的身体和心灵承受着巨大的压力时。我们对创造力、好奇心、扩展、试错和成就感的容纳能力要低得多，因为这不是生存的优先事项。然而，当我们走出这个阶段时，
those states of being and emotions become more available. And so does our sense of presence. It returns to us. It is basically like our brain is like, okay, it's safe to just be again. And And with that, I would say also comes a renewed feeling of gratitude as well. Literally, like, two days ago, I experienced one of the most intense waves of just like, oh my God, I'm so happy, I'm here. I'm so lucky, thank you, thank you, thank you. I was like riding my bike back from the farmer's market. I was listening to Ethel Cain, and I just felt this deep sense of appreciation.
这些存在状态和情绪变得更加触手可得。我们的当下感也是如此。它回到了我们身边。这基本上就像我们的大脑在说：好吧，现在重新做回自己是安全的。随着这一点，我想也随之产生了一种焕然一新的感激之情。真的，就在两天前，我经历了一次最强烈的情绪浪潮，那种“天哪，我太高兴了，我在这里。我太幸运了，谢谢，谢谢，谢谢”的感觉。我当时正骑着自行车从农夫市场回来。我听着埃瑟·凯恩（Ethel Cain）的歌，我感到了深深的感激之情。
I think I literally was like singing on my back. I was like, oh, thank you, set it out loud. And I was like, oh, I haven't felt that in a while. everything around me is like well how it's just fallen into place and as much as you guys know I just like the sentiment everything happens for a reason it undeniably felt that way those moments were feeling stuck for so long or feeling like it was never going to make sense they just made sense i was like oh god like that needed to happen didn't it that needed to happen now a disclaimer here for me if you've been following the timeline this took about three and a half years
我想我当时简直是在单车上唱歌。我当时想，哦，谢谢，大声说出来。然后我想，哦，我已经很久没有这种感觉了。我周围的一切都那么好，它是如何水到渠成的。正如你们所知道的那样，我很喜欢“一切发生皆有原因”这句话，当时这种感觉确实无可否认。那些感觉被困了那么久，或者觉得永远不会有意义的时刻，突然就有了意义。我当时想，天哪，那件事是必须要发生的，不是吗？那件事现在必须发生。这里对我有一个免责声明，如果你一直关注这个时间线，这大约花了我三年半的时间。
And I'm sure I'm not over it entirely. I think being alive always has its uncertainties. I'll slide back, slide forward. We also know from the research we mentioned before, including that 2019 paper I spoke about, that this can take much longer for some people, sometimes even a decade. People's circumstances are different. Our past hurts, trauma, our base level of self-esteem, the resources we have available to us, very practical things like finances and our obligations, can speed up or slow down this process, specifically because of how much experimentation we feel that we can do. But I do think there are some critical things that are available to us so that we can graduate from the quarter-life crisis to the quarter-life reinvention stage faster.
而且我确信我还没有完全走出来。我认为活着总会有不确定性。我会滑退，也会滑前。我们从前面提到的研究中也知道，包括我讲过的2019年的那篇论文，这可能需要更长的时间，有时甚至长达十年。每个人的情况都不同。我们过去的伤害、创伤、我们的自尊基线、我们可用的资源，比如财务和责任等非常实际的事情，可以加速或减慢这个过程，特别是由于我们觉得我们可以进行多少实验。但我确实认为，有一些关键的事情对我们是可用的，这样我们就可以更快地从四分之一人生危机毕业，进入四分之一人生重塑阶段。
Now, these aren't intended to rush the process, but they are intended to ease the process, if that makes sense, like to create less friction. And I think the most critical thing that gets us from stage two to stage three and then to stage four is one very simple ingredient, and that is just doing things. That is experiences. The curse of the quarter life crisis is that it can completely paralyze us and cause us to feel like no choices are available to us. Nothing will change.
现在，这些并不是为了催促这个过程，而是为了简化这个过程，如果这说得通的话，就像是减少摩擦。我认为让我们从第二阶段过渡到第三阶段，然后到第四阶段的最关键的事情是一个非常简单的要素，那就是行动。也就是体验。四分之一人生危机的诅咒在于，它会让我们彻底瘫痪，让我们觉得我们别无选择。什么都不会改变。
This uncertainty is forever. That inevitably prevents us from taking the kinds of risks that will help us shift timelines. The antidote for your crisis is the very thing that your brain is saying, do not do, which is just doing things and experimenting and taking a bit of a like fuck around and find out approach to your life. Like that is the only way you get through a quarter life crisis. When you are already at rock bottom, any movement will have to be upwards. That's just the laws of physics, really. Nothing you can do can make it worse if this is the worst it's ever going to be. My friend Victoria has this saying,
这种不确定性是永远的。这不可避免地阻止了我们去冒那些能帮助我们转变时间线的风险。你危机的解药正是你大脑告诉你的“不要去做”的事情，那就是去做事情、去实验，对你的生活采取一种“去他的，走着瞧”的态度。这就是你度过四分之一人生危机的唯一方法。当你已经处于人生谷底时，任何移动都只能是向上的。这其实就是物理定律。如果这是有史以来最糟糕的情况，那么你做的任何事情都不会让它变得更糟了。我的朋友维多利亚（Victoria）有这样一句名言
you can't keep asking the universe to send you more ideas for how to move forward if you are not using the ideas you already have. And I have to agree with her. If you don't show your willingness to try things, you're not going to receive more ideas for things to try. So if you want a tangible way to enact this and to just do more stuff, write down a list of everything you think might make you feel better, every single thing you have even the slightest desire to try, every single risk that feels possible for you to take in the capacity you have now and
如果你没有使用现有的想法，你就不能一直要求宇宙给你发送更多前进的想法。我不得不赞同她的观点。如果你不表现出尝试新事物的意愿，你就不会收到更多可尝试的想法。因此，如果你想要一种切实可行的方法来付诸行动并做更多的事情，那就写下一份你认为能让你感觉好一点的事情清单，每一个你甚至有一点点渴望去尝试的事情，每一个在你现有能力范围内觉得有可能去承担的风险，还有
be methodical, work through them. Even simpler, challenge yourself to just try or do something new once a week. And it doesn't even have to be big. It could be reaching out to an old friend. It could be going to something alone. It could be a solo hike. It could be a free lecture in your city. It could be going on a date with somebody even if you genuinely don't feel like it. Novelty and newness pouring that back in pushes you further towards the re-advention stage. Change requires some kind of movement. Any kind, so you have to get moving. an additional thing that I believe really helped me get to the reinvention stage. And again, it might not be the same for everybody.
有条不紊地逐一完成。更简单的方法是，挑战自己，每周尝试或做一件新事。甚至不需要很大，比如联系一个老朋友，独自去某个地方，进行一次独自远足，去你所在的城市听一场免费讲座，或者和某个人约会，哪怕你内心其实根本不想去。新鲜感和新奇感的再次注入会把你进一步推向重新改造的阶段。改变需要某种形式的运动，任何形式都可以，所以你必须行动起来。我认为真正帮助我进入重新改造阶段的另一个重要因素是——再次说明，这可能不适合所有人。
But it was also doing a little bit of reflection and analysis on how I wanted to feel in my life versus how I felt now. And then what needed to change and doing that with complete honesty. For example, I wanted to feel surrounded by people and love. At the time, I felt very lonely. Those two things can't be the only thing on the page. What's the solution? I was like, okay, I'm going to go to events where I can make friends.
那就是对我想在生活中感受到什么以及我现在的实际感受进行了一点反思和分析。然后找出需要改变的地方，并且做到完全坦诚。例如，我想要被人群和爱包围。当时我感到非常孤独。这两点不能只是写在纸上空想，解决办法是什么？我想，好吧，我要去参加能结交朋友的活动。
I'm going to be available to hanging out with people. I don't know that well. I'm going to put myself out there. I wanted to feel healthy and I wanted to feel strong in my body. At the time, I wasn't exercising. I wasn't eating well. I needed to change that. And I needed to like, remember there was a step in between that needed me to do something. I actually did this as a general activity where I put, I did like three columns. I was like ideal state, current state, three things that are going to get me there. And I just committed to them one at a time. Not all of them, one at a time. slowly and surely, and some things didn't work at all, but progress still happened with the things that did. Another thing this really taps into is the power of narrative psychology. This is the idea that we have a specific story we tell about our lives, and sometimes that story is inaccurate and it restricts us. To experience progress, we have to work on correcting that story or making it more accurate. For example, your current story might be bad things always happen to me. I've never been that lucky. Every time I've tried, I have failed. And you know what? You might have a lot of evidence for that. Heaps. But even if you have evidence, you believing that will always be your
我要对和那些我不太熟的人交往保持开放态度，我要主动表现自己。我想要感到健康，想要在身体上感到强壮。当时我没有在锻炼，也没有吃好。我需要改变这一点。我需要记住，在这之间有一个步骤需要我采取行动。我实际上把这当作一项常规活动来做，我列了三列：理想状态、现状、能让我达成目标的三个方法。我承诺一次只做一个，而不是同时做所有事情，一次只做一个。稳扎稳打，有些方法根本没用，但有用 的方法还是带来了进展。这真正触及的另一个概念是叙事心理学的力量。这个观点是，我们讲述着关于自己人生的特定故事，有时这个故事并不准确，它限制了我们。为了体验进步，我们必须致力于纠正那个故事或使其更加准确。例如，你当前的故事可能是“坏事总是发生在我身上，我从来没那么幸运，每次我尝试我都失败了”。你知道吗？你可能有很多这样的证据，堆积如山。但即使你有证据，如果你相信这永远是你的
story and expecting things to continue to go that way will inevitably create a self-fulfilling prophecy stemming not just from your experiences, not just because you have supposedly bad luck, but because you also have limiting beliefs. Psychology would tell you that to shift from stage three to stage four, a critical thing would be to examine that story, the story you tell of your life and rewrite the parts where everything happens for the worst possible reason, everything fails into a story where that is just a little bit more helpful. One way of doing so is thinking about what good things in your life have only occurred because of failure, because of your bad luck. What are the things that
故事，并且期待事情继续朝那个方向发展，就不可避免地会产生自我实现的预言。这不仅仅源于你的经历，不仅仅因为你有所谓的坏运气，还因为你有局限性的信念。心理学会告诉你，要从第三阶段过渡到第四阶段，至关重要的一点是审视那个故事——你讲述自己人生故事的部分，并把那些“每件事都因为最糟糕的原因发生、每件事都失败”的情节，重写成一个稍微更有建设性的故事。其中一种方法是思考你生活中有哪些好事仅仅是因为失败、因为你的坏运气才发生的。有哪些事情是
couldn't have happened if that thing hadn't had worked out? For me, I had a real narrative around, like, well, friends always disappoint me and relationships always fall apart. I always end up lonely. Firstly, that wasn't true. It wasn't true. But secondly, even in the times it was, it wasn't helpful. So I thought about everything in my life I was grateful for that only happened because of a breakup, only happened because a friend had disappointed me or because I'd been let down. And I thought about how it all contributed to the person I was today. And if there was even a slither of myself today that I liked, I had to be grateful for the things that put me in the position to be there.
如果那件事没有搞砸就根本不可能发生？对我来说，我确实有一种叙事，比如“朋友总是让我失望，关系总是破裂，我总是以孤独收场”。首先，这不是真的，它不是真的；其次，即使在它是真的那些时候，这种想法也毫无帮助。所以我开始思考我生活中所有感激的事情，它们之所以发生，仅仅是因为一次分手，仅仅是因为一个朋友让我失望或者我被辜负了。我思考了这一切是如何塑造了今天的我。如果今天的我身上哪怕有一丝一毫是我自己喜欢的，我都必须感谢那些把我推到今天这个位置的事情。
More generally, I think you need to have a real unconditional optimism and trust that life is working out. And it is working out in ways that you don't understand yet. but that will one day be clear. Again, this doesn't mean toxic positivity. It doesn't mean undermining when things have gone wrong, but having the narrative that focuses on the things that have gone right, on the story that is being built, perhaps even imagining every single failure
更广泛地说，我认为你需要有一种真正无条件的乐观和信任，相信生活正在好转。而且它正以你尚未理解的方式在好转，但总有一天会真相大白。再次声明，这并不意味着盲目的积极，也不意味着忽视事情出错的时候，而是要拥有一种叙事：聚焦于那些进展顺利的事情，聚焦于正在构建的故事，甚至可以把每一个失败
and moment of uncertainty as just stories you will one day tell that contributed to your success and self-realization. I think about this a lot. When something bad happens to me or something, a failure occurs, I'm like, I can't wait to tell this at a dinner table when I'm 60 and be like, and then guess what? And I thought it was the worst thing that ever happened to me. And then here is the plot twist. I think about my worst moments as my plot twists. Finally, I think getting to the quarter life reinvention stage also involves just being okay with not knowing. You will spend most
和不确定时刻想象成总有一天你会讲述的故事，正是这些故事促成了你的成功和自我实现。我经常这样想。当我遇到坏事或遭遇失败时，我想：“我迫不及待地想在我60岁时在晚宴上讲出这个故事，然后说，‘你猜怎么着？我当时以为这是我经历过的最糟糕的事，但剧情反转来了。’”我把最糟糕的时刻看作是我的剧情反转。最后，我认为达到四分之一人生重塑阶段，也包括坦然接受“未知”。你将度过大部分
of your 20s. I will spend most of my 20s. Perhaps most of my life, your life, our lives, we will where most of our life not knowing, because that is what it means to be human. That does not guarantee a bad outcome. That is your anxiety. Psychological research on the intolerance of uncertainty shows that there are a lot of people who expect the worst. And when people do practice sitting with, I don't know yet, without forcing premature resolution, they actually make better long-term decisions, even if it feels unnatural. They feel calmer sooner. They make better choices, compared to people who just want to just want to escape the discomfort, even if that means a negative guaranteed outcome. If you're having a really hard day and you're questioning, is this going to work out? A, I promise
二十多岁的时光，我也将度过大部分二十多岁的时光。也许是我生命的大部分，你的生命，我们的生命，我们将会在不确定中度过生命的大部分，因为这就是身为人类的含义。这并不保证会有糟糕的结果，这只是你的焦虑。关于对不确定性的不容忍的心理研究表明，有很多人总是预做最坏的打算。而当人们真正练习去接受“我还不知道”这种状态，而不强求过早得出结论时，他们实际上能做出更好的长期决策，即使这感觉很不自然。他们能更快地恢复平静，做出更好的选择，这与那些只想急于逃避不适感的人相比形成了鲜明对比，哪怕这意味着一个注定不好的结果。如果你今天过得很艰难，并且在质疑“这会有结果吗？”，A，我向你保证
it will. B, it's okay to just say, I don't know, but I know I will be okay if it doesn't, because I'm tough, I'm smart, I've always made it through, I'm still alive, I will make it through this again, or whatever has to happen, I will make it through that. That is, dare I say, the biggest takeaway and the biggest asset, you could have during that waiting room identity vacuum space. That is the price of experiencing your quarter life reinvention and coming out of it on the other side transformed and self-assured. And in a really great place, the price is the uncertainty. The price is the couple of, I was going to say months, it's probably going to be years, a couple of years where you're just like, oh my God, what the heck?
它一定会有。B，你可以说“我不知道，但如果结果不好我也知道自己会没事的，因为我很坚强，我很聪明，我一直挺过来了，我还活着，我能再次挺过这一切，或者无论发生什么我都能挺过去”，这是完全可以的。我敢说，这是你在等待室般的身份真空期里能拥有的最大收获和最大财富。这就是经历四分之一人生重塑并在另一端破茧成蝶、自信满满的代价。在一个真正美好的地方，这个代价就是不确定性。这个代价就是那几个——本来我想说是几个月，但很可能是几年——你只会觉得“天哪，这到底是什么鬼”的几年。
is this going to be okay? You're paying your, you're paying your dues, you're paying your taxes to the, look at how much better it is, gods. So I hope you've enjoyed this episode, especially as I test out this new theory. Has this happened to you? Do you see this process taking shape in your own life? Do you think the quarter life reinvention is a thing? And if you haven't been through it, what do you hope it brings for you. Leave a comment down below if you are listening on Spotify or send me a DM, The Quarter Life Reinvention. Legit? Has it happened to you or not? This is also your friendly reminder that you can watch full episodes of the podcast on Netflix if you haven't done so yet. We have a really cool new set. I regularly repeat outfits, so if you want to check that out,
这能行吗？你在支付你的代价，你在向“看结果变得多好啊”之神纳税。所以希望你喜欢这一集，尤其是在我测试这个新理论的时候。这发生在你身上了吗？你看到这个过程在你的生活中成形了吗？你认为四分之一人生重塑真的存在吗？如果你还没有经历过，你希望它带给你什么。如果你在Spotify上收听，请在下方留言，或者给我发私信：“四分之一人生重塑”。真的假的？它发生在你身上了吗？这也是一个温馨提示，如果你还没看过，你可以在Netflix上观看播客的完整剧集。我们有一个非常酷的新布景，我经常重复穿同一套衣服，所以如果你想去看看的话，
you are more than welcome to. There will be a link in the description. What else is down there? substack if you want to read a full episode transcript and see where I got these studies from. There are links to the studies in our substack transcripts. There's an Instagram down there. There's an email address that I don't know if you want to email me. Your thoughts. Sometimes people do. I would love to hear them.
非常欢迎。描述栏里会有一个链接。下面还有什么？如果你想阅读完整的播客文字稿并查看我引用这些研究的来源，这里有Substack链接。Substack文字稿中附有这些研究的链接。下面还有一个Instagram链接。还有一个电子邮箱，如果你想把你的想法发邮件给我，我不知道你愿不愿意。有时候大家会发，我很乐意倾听。
But yeah, just hope you enjoyed the episode. I hope that it's brought you a sense of peace and calm and that you feel better about, I don't know, the tough situation you may or may not be in. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Thank you again for listening, and we will talk very, very soon. I survived nine months in captivity, and I've spent my life exploring how other people survive what should have destroyed them. I'm Elizabeth Smart, and these are the survivor files. Every week, I'm with survivors who live through the unthinkable, abducted, stalked, controlled, and nearly silenced.
总之，希望你喜欢这一集。我希望它能给你带来一种平和与平静的感觉，让你对你可能身处（或未曾身处）的艰难处境感觉好一点。下次见，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。再次感谢大家的收听，我们很快就会再聊。我曾在被俘虏期间幸存了九个月，我的一生都在探索其他人是如何在那些本该毁灭他们的逆境中生存下来的。我是伊丽莎白·斯玛特，这里是《幸存者档案》。每周，我都与那些经历过不可思议之事的幸存者在一起，他们曾被绑架、尾随、控制，并几乎被剥夺了声音。
These are stories about what it takes to make it out alive. Listen to The Survivor Files with Elizabeth Smart on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. If your bookshelf and your For You page are equally important to your personality, welcome home. Pro Society is a weekly podcast that's part book club, part group chat for anyone who thinks Pride and Prejudice and Love Island deserve the same level of discourse. Each week, we're connecting the dots between books, the internet, and pop culture with your favorite writers, book talk creators, and plenty of overthought opinions. Yeah, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. Listen to Pro Society on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这些是关于如何活着逃脱的故事。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听伊丽莎白·斯玛特的《幸存者档案》。如果你的书架和“为你推荐”页面对你的个性同样重要，欢迎来到我们的行列。《Pro Society》是一个每周播客，它既是读书俱乐部又是群聊，适合所有认为《傲慢与偏见》和《爱情岛》值得同等程度讨论的人。每周，我们都会与你最喜欢的作家、BookTok创作者以及海量深思熟虑的观点一起，将书籍、互联网和流行文化之间的点点滴滴联系起来。是的，我着迷了。我着迷了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Pro Society》。
I'm Hoda Kotbby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotbby. You know, I'm always searching for inspiration and useful tools to maximize joy. Like when my friend Henry Winkler offered advice to aspiring actors and really anybody hoping to stand out. You're not hired just to fill time and space. You're hired to fill the space. with you. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是霍达·柯布，播客《与霍达·柯布一起寻找快乐101》的主持人。你知道的，我一直在寻找灵感和实用的工具来最大化快乐。就像我的朋友亨利·温克勒向有抱负的演员以及任何希望脱颖而出的人提出的建议：你被雇佣不仅仅是为了填补时间和空间，你被雇佣是为了用你来填满这个空间。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《与霍达·柯布一起寻找快乐101》。
Hey, this is Hayes Davenport. And Sean Clements. We host the podcast, Hollywood Handbook. Each week, we talk to someone in show business and try to help them with their careers and see what they have to offer us. Everyone has a good time, and no one gets mad at their publicists for letting them do our show. We've had a lot of great guests like Sarah Sherman, Adam Scott, Danny McBride, Ben Stillard,
嘿，我是海斯·达芬波特。还有肖恩·克莱门特。我们是播客《好莱坞手册》的主持人。每周，我们都会与演艺界的人士交谈，试图帮助他们的职业生涯，看看他们能为我们提供什么。每个人都玩得很开心，没有人因为公关人员让他们上我们的节目而对他们生气。我们邀请过许多优秀的嘉宾，比如萨拉·谢尔曼、亚当·斯科特、丹尼·麦克布莱德、本·斯蒂勒，
and a lot of other big shots that wouldn't be where they are with. us. Listen to Hollywood Handbook on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the new podcast, Solita, we share the messy reality of traveling alone as a woman. I can wait four hours for the next bus or this random dude is offering me a ride on his motorcycle. I chose option B. I'm Julie Pinero, and I travel by myself because it's a rare space where I can say yes without asking anyone else first. I'm on a mission to reclaim the word Solita, trading the pity for possibility. Listen to Solita on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及许多其他如果没有我们，就不会有今天的成就的大人物。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《好莱坞手册》。在新播客《索利塔》中，我们分享了作为女性独自旅行的凌乱现实。我可以等四个小时坐下一班车，或者这个随机的家伙主动提出让我搭他的摩托车。我选择了选项B。我是朱莉·皮内罗，我独自旅行，因为这是一个罕见的领域，我可以不用先问任何人就可以说“好”。我的使命是重新定义“索利塔”这个词，用无限可能取代同情。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《索利塔》。这是一个iHeart播客，保证由人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。